i would like a rap about losing your
virginity
lovely stuff as in as a general thing
rather than being very specifically
prying about mine
you left it wide open for you that's
exactly what the lady who took my
virginity set what i'm here to do
is to spit hot hot fire for you to end
out the show
uh to do that i'm gonna need suggestions
hey susan
welcome um what a beautiful shade of
yellow your kitchen is
um what would you like a rap about
uh spring clean up after the snow melts
spring cleanup after the snow melts
lovely stuff let's get our second
suggestion who
is it gonna be hey pete
oh gosh i'm so jealous of that beard it
really is majestic
i i haven't shaved for two months this
is my lockdown beard it's not going well
how about ernest hemingway on math
ernest hemingway on meth there we go
that's
that's even better let's get our third
suggestion
hey shaheen hello um well the ghost in
pac-man
the ghosts in pac-man amazing
i'm also jealous that you can grow a
mustache despite the fact that you are
12.
it is really true yes um
let's get our fourth suggestion so far
spring clean up after snow ernest
hemingway on meth
and the ghosts in pac-man hey emily and
emily's
emily's freaky troll friend uh let's rap
about
karen that's her name that's oh we're
rapping about
cat okay cool karen
emily's naked ginger doll lovely stuff
um i'm absolutely shocked this is
my mother often says hey chris send me a
recording of your show
i cannot do that now um so let's get one
final suggestion hello susie um susie
what would you like a rap about
um i would like a rap about losing your
virginity
lovely stuff as in as a general thing
rather than being very specifically
prying about mine
you left it wide open for you that's
exactly what the lady who took my
virginity said
so let's do this this is a freestyle rep
as i said a
made up on the spot based entirely on
your suggestions uh
i'll just ask when i'm rapping about
karen if we could see karen
uh which is emily's doll on the screen
that would be lovely um so the
suggestions to remind you spring clean
up after the snow melts
ernest hemingway on meth the ghost
impact man karen
and losing your virginity this is a
freestyle let's drop this beat and
please do not worry it will not be
anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle class white
british boy to be
let's uh let's do this jumping on the
beat then it's off we go
i'm gonna flow so neat like a street
with snow because it's crisp and white
like an albino but in the springtime
when all the snow goes it's a no-go
why cause the litter's on there all the
little tourists
that without a care they be shunning all
of the rules for the trash can
so you know you walk out yeah you dash
man with a little waist pale with a
little shovel
you clean it all up like explosion with
a rubble you gotta make sure that it's
so pristine
nice and shiny like a krispy kreme with
the glaze
yo but i'll go one better if you know a
good dealer then
send him a letter of introduction never
a text cause i'm talking about the past
and i wanna get
meth crystal meth methamphetamine
i be driving the ambulance leading the
team why
cause i'm author from farewell to arms
and i like to put the little needle
in my arms or i smoke it or i take it
there on a spoon
i'll be drunk by two in the afternoon
drink a daiquiri
or french 75 but when it comes to drugs
i've never felt more alive with the meth
like walter white from great bad ernest
hemingway
people say grand dad or pops because he
drinks at the bar
all day with a long beard looking like
he's got a little stray
cat attached to his face with the claws
when you're playing pac-man there's no
room to pause you
gotta get the little dots get the little
buttons but if you see a big
one i'm gonna shove it in the face is
the ghost i mean what i'm referring i
make them extinct yeah i never preserve
them i gobble them
one two three so many i take that forth
like i'm taking the cherry but
virginity that's a natural link i gotta
make sure that my dick don't stink so
i'm gonna get my rocks off with that
lady otherwise she'd be telling my guys
i'm too
crazy in the uk i should make sense
cause it's only 16 just the age of
consent
in the u.s everybody just screams saying
chris that's illegal cause it's
18 i say whoa guys i will make a mistake
that is why in britain you can often see
matt gates going
over there looking underage if you're
following the news then you might be
enraged
you can lose it yeah it's cause for
firing sleep
with boss's daughter and breaker heim
and then he's gonna say
doctor check that still it's kind of
old-fashioned like it's over the hill
last one
oh she's the bright thing she canceled a
strange karen like she's on the right
wing
usually angry and she won't wear masks
or no clothes
and i'll take to test the fact karen
what's your skin so blue for it makes no
sense yeah
open these doors and see got your tits
out they be like
double f's never seen a lady who makes
me so erect in fact karen let me
proposition you gal i wanna go
down on that ginger doll i really wanna
have fun i see
karen wanna [ __ ] it and when i come i'll
be thinking about those muppets oh yes
you make me stand to attention the most
sexual thing since i saw
jim henson over there yeah you know i
prefer it karen
the sexiest puppet since little kermit
yeah
thank you very much that was a lot
grosser than i wanted it to be
and i blame all of you for that that is
not how we do things in my country we're
usually very polite okay let's try this
one okay and if you can spotlight things
at random oh nice
cool let's uh let's do oh my gosh
strange thing right there in your hand
white black like a tiny panda but this
one no
save that for later it's a type of butt
plug a type of vibrator
face of a little tiny bear if you are a
paramedic then you better beware take
care when you're climbing
up the ladder don't want to get hit when
the fire gets hotter gotta
keep that nice little neon yellow gotta
be very brave heroic fellow when you're
going in the building oh that's a nice
little heirloom i'd kill for a tomato
like that
though instead it looks like a tiny
squash but the sides are red it's got a
little bit of green looking like a
spider wanna fry that
up get it right inside you now this
won't take it no mistaker
let me put it in that paper stapler
gotta get tiny little bits of metal and
it bends gotta get those sheath
everybody intends to use a hole punch
to use a bulldog clip if you wanna get a
little shelf better measure it
otherwise it will slip out of the wall
get it retracting i'm having a ball
going down there you're retracting it
mate go over there like a lightsaber
taking a little banana around it might
alarm yeah to know these are slightly
too ripe for my taste so
i don't like it when it's got the sugar
spot so the little bit of brown i'm like
nah not hot never put it on my toast
instead make banana bread
but tiny little ukulele i'm sick to my
hind teeth are playing with the six
strings need to get two less yeah we be
mixing over in hawaii with the wunderbar
like the germans now where you are
looking like a little baggie to be full
of weed
very hard to say yeah take heed and my
advice you can bring it closer to me is
it illegal drugs or some type of tea
and it's a tiny little sphere and you
bring it in the room looking like we're
very close to celestial moon
oh calling that celine i love it glowing
up over
exposing the screen this is a lovely
thing i'm gonna chow right down on the
chicken wing i need to get that buffalo
tastes so nice when i put it in my mouth
i'll be
liking that spice from the chicken wing
to the little bit on chessboard that's
the king never seen queen's gambit it's
hard to tell
an old black ghost second go to hell if
you're playing gary
kasparov that's the reward go and stab
that dolphin with a sword
make sure you make that beast extinct
stab it in the blowhole then it sinks
right down there
uh animals i hate with the bottlenose
wanna kick flip when i skate gotta show
all of the trucks gotta show all of the
bearings love it you're a little skater
and you're sharing your little longboard
oh fancy that you've got a
little match and you've got a weird cat
with a little green thing on its head on
the collar
hope that it returns and you feed it
tomorrow there we go the beat the beat
ran out so that's uh that's that
thank you very much and thank you for
indulging me with an encore that feels
very special
um you're a lovely i will see you guys
again sometime goodbye
and farewell